[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
while pushing for new gun safety
measures last week president biden
revealed that he owns two shotguns
that's in addition to his two handguns
there you go champ you think he thinks
is real oh yeah he thinks as well
following the january 6 capital attack
authorities have arrested more than 840
defendants
you're really going to have a good time
later incidentally 840 defendants is
also the technical term for the catholic
church
but man you cannot find a lie due to a
pandemic baby boom in norway the
country's branch of ikea has recently
created a catalog of more than 800 baby
names and as always you'll have to
assemble them yourself
on sunday authorities arrested 31 white
supremacists in the back of a u-haul on
their way to terrorize an lgbtqia plus
pride of it and it honestly got me
asking
what are they so mad about so let's find
out in a segment called y'all mad about
what
look at these mother
what are you all so mad about are y'all
mad that it's pride month and you've
done nothing in your life to be proud
about
are y'all mad that the next time you
wear matching outfits with your little
friends it'll be in jail
are y'all mad that you're that white and
probably still bad at lacrosse why are
you mad
maybe you're mad that the only thing
smaller than your world view is your
upper lip
you must save a fortune in chapstick why
are you mad did you just find out that
half of the dave matthews band is black
that why y'all mad why are you mad are
y'all mad that you started giving
yourselves bad haircuts before the
pandemic
why are you mad are y'all mad that you
have more pockets than tinder matches
your cargo ass motherfu
are y'all mad that the gays can get
married and you can't even score a first
date
the u-haul ass [ __ ] are you mad because
you all keep chanting we shall not be
replaced yet you look completely
interchangeable
these mug shots look like an unwinnable
game of guess who
or is it that you're mad because you got
a white supremacist elected president in
2016 and you are still losers in a
country that is systematically built for
you to win
probably that one
look i have a lot of questions about
this whole situation but my number one
question is y'all mad about what
cosmetics company revlon has filed for
bankruptcy and i don't know who's
responsible but maybe it's maybelline
[Applause]
new yorkers have recently been spotting
dolphins in the new york harbor now when
asked why the dolphins said
[Applause]
in an effort to combat public urination
boston's transportation authority will
install urine detection sensors in
several elevators now if you've never
seen a urine detection sensor here's a
photo
[Applause]
and finally due to president biden's age
democratic lawmakers are reportedly
questioning if he will be fit to run for
reelection now i think he's fit to run
it's his climbing i'm worried about
[Applause]
you guys that was his monologue did you
like the monologue
you know what
i gotta say so far this is the best
season two finale we've ever done but
we've got a lot of news to cover tonight
so let's keep it moving
oh okay i mean
yeah she's gonna get on with it finally
[Laughter]
according to new data released this week
covent cases are rising in every part of
the country um
you know as our gas prices um interest
rates and global temperatures but that's
okay
hell that's fine do you think i give a
rip
you think i care at all do you think
think think and
just like that amber broke
the news rattled her so badly she
couldn't say another word because that's
just how it is these days it gets worse
and worse and we're supposed to be okay
cut the [ __ ] things are unhinged and
they're never going back to normal never
never i say never and just like that
tear bro
sure he came off like he had things
under control but in reality he was just
as messed up and twisted as the rest of
us because that's what we really are
tortured souls grasping at any lifeline
in this cruel world but it's not coming
you fools fools you're all foreign and
just like that jeff broke
we all thought he'd be able to bring
this sketch home but jeff spun just like
the rest of them but that's not going to
happen with me i'm not going to melt
down just because i heard some bad news
like dolphins will be extinct in 10
years i got the dolphins the graphic
department and just like that
patrick
broke now i've known that dude for years
and i've never seen him like that he's
melting down faster than a glacier and
oh my god what are we going to do when
the glaciers melt we're doomed we're
doomed and just like that
nandy broke what is wrong with everyone
today who's gonna break next wally wally
if you mess up a cue card i'll swear to
god
just like that mikey p broke and let me
just say i have never messed up a cue
card a day in my wife i mean life it
says life on the
and just like that wally broke hi i'm
zachary i'm not even gonna waste any
time i'm just going to immediately lose
my [ __ ]
and just like that zachary broke
hi i'm ian i'm the writer of this sketch
isn't it funny
[Applause]
i think it's great
in fact it's
probably the best thing i'll ever write
oh my god
did i peek at 32 and just like that ian
broke
talking up his own sketch what a friggin
douche
i can't stand him you know what i'm
going to punch him i'm going to turn
around and i'm going to punch him in his
dumb face and just like that jenny broke
ian's jaw in 11 places and the crowd
went wild because they are just as sick
as the rest of us sure
we're all broken but if you think about
it
so are you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you